[Música]
[Aplausos]
quiero comenzar haciéndole una pregunta
a todos ustedes
primero que nada ustedes creen en el
amor a primera vista
bueno
yo lo encontré en el año 2007 en el
taekwondo en el 2013 en la medicina y en
el 2016 de gm y se los cuento
soy jugo del castillo medallista de los
juegos panamericanos clima 2019 y además
estudiante de medicina de esta
prestigiosa universidad
[Aplausos]
muchas personas no lo saben pero 90% de
mi vida se ha basado en insistir y
luchar por mis sueños cada vez que
alguien me ha dicho que no puedo lograr
hacer ambas cosas ha sido un motivo más
para seguir adelante y demostrarles que
si puedo yo les vengo decir aquí a todos
ustedes que sean los primeros en lograr
lo imposible
y mi deporte es taekwondo en la
modalidad de ponce la competencia es de
esta manera
entran los dos competidores o atletas
nos saludamos de una manera marcial
y entramos a hacer lo que se denomina
una forma
parado frente a nosotros hay varios
árbitros los cuales van a decidir quién
va a ganar eso depende de la fuerza de
la técnica de la presentación y de la
maestría que tenga cada atleta en mi
caso yo sentí que la medicina y el
deporte de alto rendimiento se
enfrentaban para ver quién ganaba
quieren saber quién ganó
bueno vamos a dividir esto de una manera
muy bonita lo vamos a dividir en rounds
primer round
es que yo tengo uso de razón he sido
médico
cuando yo era muy pequeño tenía
muchísimos juguetes tenía carritos
aviones muñecos
y los muñecos especialmente me dan risa
les voy a contar porque muchos de ellos
terminaban sin cabeza sin brazos y
piernas pero saben qué hacía con eso los
intercambiaba hacia trasplantes desde
chiquita y decía trasplante de brazos de
pierna de cabeza y creo que de ahí ha
sido y estilo cirujano
pero había un este un juguete al cual yo
te sobre mucho y me encantaba jugar con
él inclusive me dio muchísimo
eres el kit de médico ese kit que tenía
un estetoscopio un martillo un otoscopio
las curitas y una que otra cosita o
elemento que se utiliza para las
consultas médicas
en ese tiempo
pero jugaba a curar a mi abuelo
yo sentía que mi abuelo tenía una gripe
que no se le pasaba nunca todos los días
iba a su cama me sentaba en su falda le
ponía el estetoscopio en el pecho le
pasaba la curita por la cabeza y le
decía abuelito yo te voy a curar
sin embargo un día despierta voy a su
cuarto y no lo vi más
pues me enteré que mi abuelito había
fallecido de un terrible cáncer al
pulmón
pasaron los años
y va con la carrera por la carretera con
mi familia y en eso al costado nuestro
paso en carro a toda velocidad nosotros
de por si ahí vamos rápido pero el que
iba a nuestro costado iba volando y en
eso diez segundos después a lo lejos
vemos que se le ve una nube de polvo
inmensa y al llegar al sitio encontramos
a una familia dentro de un auto
totalmente siniestrado
como si se tratase de un reflejo y elige
a mi familia para en el auto vamos a
bajar ayudarlos porque necesitan nuestra
ayuda
me bajé fui corriendo a abrir la puerta
de ese auto y me encontré con una
familia
los padres los niños
los dos niños tenían cortes en la cabeza
la madre felizmente estaba ilesa pero el
padre tenía un corte muy grande en la
frente estaba sangrando y estaban
todavía los restos del vidrio en su
herida
lo que hice yo fue primero sacarlos del
auto auxiliar los limpiar las heridas y
llamar una ambulancia porque de verdad
lo requerían el auto estaba totalmente
siniestrado
en ese momento me di cuenta de algo algo
que cambió mi vida y es que me apasionó
me pareció magnífico el hecho de poder
ayudar a salvar una vida y desde ese
momento me di cuenta que quería ser
médico todas las dudas se disiparon
mucho antes
en el año 2007 y estaba jugando con mi
vecino y vamos caminando por la calle
por mi casa
y en eso veo algo llamado escuela de
taekwondo
para mí en ese entonces era chino
después descubrí que era coreano
y en eso para poder para poder descubrir
que era el taekwondo
entro a la escuela
me asomo por la puerta y veo algo que de
verdad me enamoro
y a niños gritando dando golpes patadas
altos y en verdad eso me encantó
y eso es muy fan de dragon ball z
y en ese tiempo yo quería ser goku y
quería ser mi hija me llame ja
y corriendo a mi casa y le dije mamá yo
quiero meterme a esto yo quiero
practicar taekwondo
y es así que después de cinco años entre
la selección nacional
y después de muchos años más obtuve una
medalla mundial y varias medallas
panamericanas y una medalla en los
juegos panamericanos que se realizaron
este año aquí en lima
[Aplausos]
segundo round
ustedes conocen a paula pareto
paula pareto es una judoka medallista de
los juegos rio-2016 medallista mundial y
además cursando su carrera de medicina
obtuvo todos estos logros deportivos
actualmente se encuentra se encuentra
cursando su residentado médico en
traumatología y ortopedia al igual que
yo también lo deseo yo también quiero
hacer traumatólogo
muchas personas tienen el cliché y el
chip muy metido en la cabeza de que un
deportista no le gusta el estudio es
flojo y a la vez tampoco es que tenga
habilidades pero eso es totalmente falso
es una falacia que nos han metido muchas
películas y tal vez algunas series
era el año 2013 y yo tenía que tomar una
terrible decisión para mí
muchas personas me decían que no iba a
poder lograr entrar a estudiar medicina
o seguir con la medicina y al mismo
tiempo
ser deportista de alto rendimiento
yo ya había realizado una serie de
decisiones y bastantes acciones
complicadas
la primera y la que todo el mundo me
dice es por qué lo hiciste es la que
quiero contarles ahorita yo no fui a mi
viaje de promoción por sacrificar bueno
sacrifiqué en viaje de promoción para
poder viajar a corea a corea del sur a
entrenar taekwondo
este es el sueño de total con dista
muchas personas me han dicho no te
arrepientes pues no no me arrepiento
porque cumplí mi sueño y estaba seguro
de lo que estaba haciendo
además por esos momentos
tenía que estudiar para entrar a la
universidad y me metí a una academia de
estudios esas muy conocidas y en una de
esas había un profesor el cual siempre
me decía no sé si lo decía en un tono
burlón o lo hacía para que me quedara y
estudiando me decía hugo tú tienes que
dejar el deporte de todas maneras no vas
a estudiar no vas a poder estudiar
medicina y no vas a poder hacer deporte
profesor g si me estás escuchando en
estos momentos o si me llegas a escuchar
te vengo a decir que lo logré pude hacer
ambas cosas y lo sigo haciendo y lo
seguiré haciendo
es así que continué con mis estudios y a
la vez con mi deporte
también cuál es mi secreto dos palabras
decisión y disciplina
estas dos palabras me ayudaron muchísimo
tanto así que un día estaba en mi cama y
me despierto con un dolor sumamente
fuerte en el abdomen
me tuvieron que llevar al hospital y en
este me dijeron hugo tenemos que
operarte urgentemente
en ese momento y era el año 2014 yo
tenía una meta muy importante para mí
tiene que competir en el campeonato
mundial de taekwondo en mexico
estaba a un mes de la competencia y me
tenían que operar
embargo con decisión y disciplina dos
semanas después competi y obtuve la
medalla de plata en el campeonato
mundial
yo sabía que fuera algo muy arriesgado
podía haber arriesgado mi salud mi
deporte sin embargo el que no arriesga
definitivamente no gana
round 3
es aquí donde vienen los juegos
panamericanos
tenía que tomar una decisión muy
importante los juegos panamericanos
implicaron una preparación muy fuerte
tanto en lo físico emocional y
psicológico
y entrenador lo tenía muy claro y me
dijo hugo tienes que dejar la medicina
para mí fue devastador ya no era ya no
era una decisión mía sino algo que tenía
que dejar
tiene que decir entre uno de los dos de
todas maneras pero yo tenía un sueño era
competir en estos juegos y demostrarle a
todo el mundo de mostrarle a todos mis
amigos a mis seres queridos la razón por
la cual no había podido estar con ellos
en los momentos más importantes además
era la primera vez que mi modalidad el
punte se incluía en un circuito
panamericano
y además para poner la cereza al pastel
y analizar acá en lima en mi ciudad y en
mi país yo quería regalarle una medalla
a mi país
bueno al final decidí dejar la carrera
por un año y no me arrepiento
esta decisión implicaba alargar una
carrera que de por si es larga
y acá va a dejar compañeros con los
cuales compartimos muchísimo amistad
muchísimos momentos bonitos durante seis
años pero sobre todo
yo no sabía si de verdad y obtener una
medalla pero yo decidí seguir mi sueño y
seguí adelante con decisión y disciplina
y es así que obtuve la medalla de plata
ustedes se preguntarán o bueno dirán
hugo pero es una máquina como puede ser
la ambas cosas no es así yo también soy
una persona me doy tiempo tanto para mi
familia mis amigos y mis seres queridos
de hecho tengo una enamorada de mexico
en méxico
es una relación a distancia y créeme que
una realiza una distancia también
requiere bastante decisión y disciplina
pero en el corazón
quiero terminar hablándoles acerca de la
definición que para mí es la disciplina
y nada como un maestro coreano me dijo
disciplina
es
darte tiempo para tu familia para tus
seres queridos y amigos
tener claro el camino y hacia dónde
quieres llegar
y además saber que todo el esfuerzo todo
sacrificio y una recompensa y si tienes
claro hacia dónde quieres llegar para ti
eso no será un sacrificio sino será una
gran emoción
el taekwondo significa golpe patada y el
camino a la excelencia y de verdad lo es
puedo dar fe de eso el taekwondo es su
método de vida su método de excelencia
y a los primeros en lograr lo imposible
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]